ladies and gentlemen please welcome
two-time Academy Award winner Barbra
Streisand
from among the five gifted nominees
tonight the winner could be for the
first time a woman or or it could be
also for the first time an
african-american or it could be one of
the three directors who brought their
own scripts to life on the screen one of
which has become the most successful
movie ever made congratulations to each
of you for your astonishing achievement
here are the nominees for Best Director
for Avatar James Cameron he's such a
passionate person and that's so helpful
to come to work and and work with the
director that is eager to push the
envelope for The Hurt Locker Kathryn
Bigelow I think she really exemplifies
the spirit of the independent filmmaker
it's been great having somebody with
that great sense of visual style and
story and character and she's a true
professional for inglourious basterds
Quentin Tarantino he has the openness
stamp on the story this directors medium
it starts with the director and ends
with the director but the set his church
he is God and no heretics allowed for
precious based on the novel push by
Sapphire Lee Daniels he wanted to make a
film that was true to the book for
minutia two really important issues he
asked me about those things
I wasn't expecting to have that much
input for up in the air jason reitman he
made a movie that came you know really
from his brain and from his heart I
think it's a rare thing that we're
blessed with children who follow in our
footsteps and then frankly do better
than we are
and the winner is well the time has come
Kathryn Bigelow
this is the first Academy Award and
second nomination tonight for Kathryn
Bigelow
thank you
this really is there's no other way to
describe it it's the moment of a
lifetime first of all this is so so
extraordinary to be in the company of
such power with my fellow nominees such
powerful filmmakers who have inspired me
and I have admired for some of them for
decades and thank you to every member of
the Academy this is again the moment of
a lifetime I would not be standing here
if it wasn't for Mark Boal who risked
his life for the words on a page wrote
such a courageous screenplay
that I was fortunate enough to have an
extraordinary cast bring that screenplay
to life in Jeremy Renner Anthony Mackie
and Brian Geraghty and I think the
secret to directing is collaborating and
I had truly an extraordinary group of
collaborators in my crew Barry Aykroyd
and Kelly Julia Sun and Bob Morosky
Chris Ennis ray Beckett Richard Stutzman
and and if I could just also thank my
producing partners in Greg Shapiro and
Nick Chartier and my wonderful agent
Bryan several and the people of Jordan
who were such a so hospitable to us when
we were shooting and I just like to
dedicate this to the women and men in
the military who risked their lives on a
daily basis in Iraq and
around the world and may they come home
safe thank you
you